kelsey gabbard is pro-american a
lifelong democrat former presidential
candidate we're always grateful to have
her join us tonight tell us about thanks
so much for coming on so if you were in
the house still you laughed less left
after the end of last cycle but if you
were still there
you i don't think you'd be able to say a
single word without being denounced as
pro-russia
which is a problem for democracy i think
the real question here tucker that we're
all asking these leaders in washington
is what's the rush why are our political
leaders from both parties rushing this
through without giving the american
people the opportunity to actually look
at what's in the bill and examine what
the cost will be to us
not just today with this bill but with
the next round of 40 billion dollars or
whatever billions they will ask for in
the next round in the next round in the
next round the reality is there's no
imminent threat to the safety security
and freedom of the united states
coming to us from russia
in fact there's no imminent threat or
even long-term threat of russia invading
finland or sweden russia can barely hold
on to a very small sliver of ukraine
right now so again i asked these leaders
what is the rush what we do know is that
the bidet administration has failed to
clearly define any
objective
in this proxy war in ukraine they have
failed to define what winning looks like
so clearly there is no end in sight
without that being defined we can look
at afghanistan and iraq as very recent
examples of what happens when you don't
have that clearly defined mission and so
the american people were struggling with
high inflation basic necessities that
people need to live costs increasing and
yet with this 40 billion dollars of
funding and what will come next and next
and next the american people deserve to
know what this will cost us financially
what it will cost our economy and what
will cost our national security with the
increased potential of a nuclear
conflict if this is allowed to continue
you know the more i think about it takes
a lot of gall for eye patch mccain to
attack moms you're worried about baby
formula as quote pro russia i mean
that's probably one that's one of the
most outrageous things i think i've ever
heard now that i'm thinking about i mean
why not just answer the question why why
the attacks what does that tell you
it tells you that they don't really want
the american people to know
what is in this bill and what will come
next and what it will truly cost us not
just a few of us but all of us as the
american people today and what appears
to be if we continue down this path for
the long term to come that should be a
huge red flag for the american people as
they look at leaders in washington
resorting to name calling and smearing
rather than actually providing these
clear explanations to the american
people
man you've been smeared since day one
you've never lost your composure or
moved off course and i i definitely
admire the way you've handled the
attacks
tulsi gabbard thank you
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight